et voilà qui nous amène à la 14e édition
de la semaine du goût la gastronomie ou
plus simplement les saveurs sont à
l'honneur dans ce domaine les pratiques
et les modes changent très vite les
historiens se sont même penché sur le
sujet alors tendance dominante depuis 30
ans moins de sucre et le retour de
l'aigre doux marie-pierre samitier
alexandre de cuite les bavaroises
les polonaises les religieuses les
éclairs au chocolat
la pâtisserie fait tourner la tête les
gourmands qu'est ce qu'il ya doivent ils
ont retrouvé un gros gâteau cette fois
ci on fait un panachage depuis dix ans
le chocolat règne en maître sur nos
péchés de gourmandise
mais les mousses légère ou le ventoux on
retravaille les mousses de marron pour
les introduire entre des génoises et ça
ce sont vraiment les tendances actuelles
de travail et les mousses les bavarois
la légèreté le des sucres âge et très
peu de beurre depuis trente ans on a
tous des sucres et la crème fouettée par
exemple on est passé à 60 grammes de
sucre par litre de crème
alors que dans les années 70 on pense
souvent
c'était entre 200 et 250 g 300 g de
sucre au leap oms qui faisait en faut 20
25 voire 30 % de sucre par rapport à
l'aspect après le sucré le salé et le
retour de l'aigre-doux saveurs qu'on
aimait dans la rome antique et au
moyen-âge pour accompagner une dorade
cette préparation de légumes en aigre
doux sauce obtenu avec du sucre à la
base de questionner les deux pays
donc c'est une et c'est une recette
qu'on a remis un peu au goût du jour
parce que le sucré salé
il faut ce qui est toujours bien sûr
tout cela ravit les papilles et fascine
les touristes qui comprennent un ce
qu'est le lèche vitrine à la française